[Music]
do you guys remember
this little gadget oh yeah the
flamethrower they're not a plane thrower
not playing a friend what is it so elon
musk's back i don't know how many years
ago he created a
a flamethrower a little he created a
company flamethrower yeah
he has a separate company called the
boring company and he just has like
[ __ ] jokes the first one was a hat
products that he likes to come out with
yeah and he came out with a flamethrower
product
and it's called not a flamethrower for
whatever reasons
why and he made 10 000 of these and they
sold and it sold out like within a day
or two they were like 500 bucks or
something
yeah very affordable and what do you do
with it
you light things on fire with it well
most people got it so they could resell
it and they were reselling them for
thousands of dollars
okay so at the time uh
you know there's all right i guess to
this day there really isn't any laws
against
flamethrowers and there isn't any uh
you know incidences that have happened
to
to need to have laws around
flamethrowers until now
until until today no well
nothing big happened but uh
uh law enforcement in europe especially
they've been cracking down on people
that have
these and now the people are traveling
with these what
yeah can't trust for whatever reasons
they're traveling with them and
obviously when you go through tsa or
whatever they can see and kind of like
what the [ __ ] is that and so over the
years it's been happening so it's been
kind of quiet
about this but it's coming out that
whenever law enforcement come across a
flame thrower
especially elon musk's ones they're
being confiscated
oh wow and they've been resold no no i
think they're just being confiscated now
and like they're in that like they've
confiscated like five thousand of these
so half of them
yeah they can roll around with a flame
five thousand dollars
yeah obviously it's just reselling too
you know like if you're reselling it
then obviously you're shipping it out
so they're also uh keeping track of the
shipments
yeah and they're they're they're taking
it during the shipment of it elon said
that the reason why
they named it not a flamethrower is to
skirt around restrictions
when like sending it to other countries
or whatever or like to to
ship it to people that's why they he
named it that it is a massive butane
torch
it is yeah so basically that's all it is
it's like that lighter but it's
times 20. and here is it it's an action
here kind of sort of
but yeah i think he's roasting a
marshmallow or something
that's the only way to do it yeah but
yeah so this guy
he's an american and he was traveling in
sweden
i believe let me double check you could
be an american bringing it
oh london he was in london actually so
an american
his name is max craddick he is traveling
in london and
he went on to a party bus out of all
places
with the flamethrower this is what makes
him look stupid man i don't know if he
had it just opened and i can just carry
it like a gun like hey i got a
flamethrower we're going to party bus
let's do this you know
shots all around this isn't a dirt this
is not a nerf gun
this is a flame thrower or maybe he just
had it in a box whatever reasons he got
caught
with it on this party bus and now
the only reason why he's not in jail and
he credits his lawyer for
this and this is pretty [ __ ] pretty
epic epic he was like
the reason why i'm not in jail right now
in international uh
prison or whatever my laura asked the
judge quote do you really want to be the
guy on international news keeping an
american in jail over this
toy and he thinks that was alone was the
reason why he
didn't end up in jail and was able to go
home you know you know scotch-free
but yeah authorities are taking up these
flamethrowers not a flamethrowers
and uh now in new york especially
they're trying to introduce a bill
that will make it illegal to possess the
flamethrower in that state
and obviously it's it's not um it hasn't
made it
out of the committees yet but they're
working on it and so this is all like
unprecedented
like legal stuff uh and then basically
the
the responsible statement here uh uh
from from
the government allowing untrained people
to own these machines purely for the
value of entertainment is dangerous
which you know it goes i mean so is a
car casey can you google
if flamethrower is illegal in california
because i think one of the things that
i looked at is it's not a a lot of these
flamethrowers are not illegal i don't
think it's illegal here
they're not a real one like the world
war ii one with the [ __ ] backpack
that has the gasoline [ __ ] in it yeah
and a real like a real
like a constant flame at the tip yeah
that one is illegal
that's right real flamethrowers are
legal in california assuming an inspire
aspiring owner is willing to jump
through a regulatory hoop in fact flame
borders are completely legal in 48
states only maryland bans them outright
and california is the only other state
that is imp imposes even
minimal impediments to ownership look at
that look at that though that's a real
flamethrower like that's not not a
flamethrower it's a dragon's [ __ ]
mouth dude
yeah that's not good that's scary they
said that flamethrower's knife it's not
about you getting burnt up they said it
was about the flames being around you
sucking up so much oxygen
you can't breathe it kills you instantly
because it sucks all the air out of your
oxygen because that's how hot it is in
the flame
so it's not about you getting burned by
that's [ __ ] dragon's breath
that's crazy how come people aren't
robbing banks of flame throwers and [ __ ]
then you burn them
yourself oh yeah the money that's a
sloppy i mean i'm sure
money is flattering percentage of
flamethrower guys got killed by their
own flamethrower the gas going
everywhere
oh it's a dangerous ass weapon okay we
gotta go back to the drawing board babe
what
no you just you just threaten people
with it if you have a flamethrower
indoors and you're like watch out or
i'll shoot i'll be like ha you'll kill
yourself
yeah indoors the flamethrower is not
good right you're gonna burn yourself
down
through it or like even when you're
outside the we have to consider like the
wind factor
oh my god
all you gotta do with the just someone
come with a big fan and you can fight
the flame throw a guy with a big
fan that's true we gotta plug the fan in
let's try that's true yeah i do want to
use one though me too
i want to see i didn't use one on um
csi i don't know hawaii the hawaii
what's the hawaii show called
wi-fi oh five oh yeah you're on hawaii
five oh and you did a flamethrower yeah
nikki chang and i and i come out with a
flamethrower cool
it's a real one uh yeah was it hot it
was i mean i don't know how real i don't
think it was that but we had yeah we had
i had the backpack on in the whole thing
it was kind of cool but it was kind of
like was everyone staring at you like
don't [ __ ] around yeah that was like
doing the whole
i had to rehearse it and like with the
stuntmen and all that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that's tight i forgot about that just
remember yeah i did that thing
i want to take one in the desert and do
it that's fine i want to blow a bazooka
like i want to use a bazooka thingy
we could do it in um cambodia cambodia
there's no restrictions on
anything there is but you basically
bribe the military
it's like it's like an unofficial
tourist thing it's like it's like
tourism but not really like
everyone knows you can do it you pay a
good amount of money and then you can
like ride a tank you could [ __ ]
use their military you're basically
using the military equipment
like disneyland yeah but like you're
paying
them for this it's like churro you're
like
but i don't think it's like legal but
there is a thing what do you i mean
how do you not get caught like there's a
[ __ ] tank that
someone a tourist is driving or maybe
they're so used to it oh it's just
another tourist bar in the tank again
is it like in a like an enclosed space
yeah it's like their military uh
like you're going to like their camp and
yeah how good is this cambodian military
i don't know i i don't know i was asking
like how
intense is their equipment i mean every
every country got some kind of military
right i mean they're all different
levels don't even love them
cambodia is not known for its prowess
i don't know [ __ ] like they showed me
two different military times i'm like
yeah they're both pretty [ __ ] intense
for me
you're not sure like i'm sure you can
tell the difference if you look at him
you'll probably be like
that one will [ __ ] that one up for sure
that guy's sure it's not even tucked in
oh [ __ ] but some military stuff you'd be
surprised like so basic you know you can
sell
tanks and those helicopters and you're
like what the
it looks my car inside looks more
advanced than this
dashboard of this helicopter yeah you
ever seen those north korean parades and
[ __ ]
it's like people walking around and they
got like missiles that look hella old
missile that's being pulled by 20 humans
there's like a 1960s military parade
they're saying even like
airplanes that we fly on like no keys
it's keyless
it's just like you hello was it a retina
scan or something no
the way that this is already on or
something the push starts just push this
on it's like there's no like password
nothing no
they're like people can get on and just
steal this stuff because it's just like
they're not you would think you get on
these planes and inside it looks like a
lincoln navigator or something but it's
not
my phone is more it's just like playing
some old gauges and like we're gonna
take one
hundred people in the sky if you're
gonna jack it you better know how to
[ __ ] fly it because i can't imagine
me taking it i'm gonna be like
now what the [ __ ] do you wanna be able
to jackie but if you're a pilot true
you could jack anything you want any
time yeah it depends on where you when
you want the flashlight another good
thing is you want
yeah you want like a plane to probably
basic because you don't want anything
going wrong like the
the navigation my apple carplay is not
working and we're on the sky and [ __ ]
in wonder woman when you take the plane
i'm like you're from the 1940s and now
in the 80s you know how to fly a plane
like everyone's
in a jet plane technology didn't change
at all
like what i don't know the old school
plans don't you have to have someone
like rotate the propeller first
and then you run inside real quick have
you guys wanted to fly plane check
absolutely i think that's going to be
our next thing that's been my dream
bart's going to be outside
all right ready
yeah a sidekick did tell me to stay away
from small planes
oh [ __ ] richie villains i know i was
like what
yeah stay with them small planes my
friend's learning right now he's doing
the flight school thing
sick yeah it looks pretty fun he's
always updating it i'm all like how are
you recording on your instagram in the
sky they have autopilot
isn't that funny autopilot autopilot on
a [ __ ] plane
yes isn't that where autopilot came from
yeah i think so pilots
oh wow it's small though it's like a
four seater like a car
i know i mean i like the idea but
there's only one mistake
right on that plane hey if it's your
time to go man
i ride motorcycles but i you know but i
feel like mother's like you pull over
like something's wrong you know what's
crazy a lot of my friends at skydive
they actually feel it's way safer safer
because of the amount of time you have
to make decisions
so for them they're like if it takes me
60 seconds
to hit the ground i have a full minute
or two or three minutes
to correct my situation versus a
motorcycle or base jumping
it's instant you [ __ ] up you're on the
ground you're dead right or you're
scraping and you're flying across the
floor
people that are that skydive or they fly
planes are like i got 60 sec i could
take my time
is it this parachute no is it this one
you can you know
like hey i think i'm gonna die in like
60 seconds like you can do what do i do
you can be like you just you can have
your whole life i could take it all in
for two minutes
i got 20 seconds you should get a second
opinion too i don't know
yeah let's see another sidekick maybe or
maybe another psychic yeah
like yeah definitely those small planes
stay away from
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you